من مصر والحديث الذي لا ينتهي هذه الايام
عن اخر اخبار الفنانه المعتزله حلا شيحه
تثير الجدل مره اخرى بين الجمهور المتابع
لها والعنوان العريض صوره دون حجاب
الفنانه التي اثرت الصمت حول مساله اشاعات
طلاقها من الداعيه المعز مسعود حذفت جميع
صورها
خلعت فيها حجابها حاله لم تكتفي بذلك حيث
كتبت رساله غامضه على انستجرام حول عدم
ثقتها باحد واغلقت التعليقات على صورها
بسبب الانتقادات الحاده له المزيد حول جدل
حاله شيحه في الشارع المصري من القاهره
سمر بشات من جديد تطل عليكم
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
مره اخرى تتصدر الفنانه حلا شيحه مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وتصبح ترند حيث نشرت
صورا لها بدون حجاب ونشر التعليقات مفادها
انه لا باس ان يبدا الانسان حياته من
اليوم وان الانسان يتعلم من اخطائه كما
حذفت صورها مع زوجها الداعيه معز مسعود ما
دعا الجمهور يستنتج انفصالهما ولكن دون
نفي او تاكيد من اي منهما انت مكبر
الموضوع كده ليه كل الحكايه اني بحب
الهدوم مش اكتر وحتى الان لا توجد معلومات
مؤكده عن عودتها للتمثيل وان كانت تهنئتها
للفنان اشرف زكي بفوزه بمنصب نقيب المهن
التمثيليه مؤخرا اثار جدلا واعتبره البعض
اشاره منها برغبتها للعوده للفن هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي تثير فيها حلا الشيحه
الجدل حول ارتدائها او خلعها للحجاب ومنذ
اعوام قليله خلعت الحجاب وظهرت في
مهرجانات فنيه وشاركت في عده اعمال مسلسل
خيانه عهد مع يسرا وزلزال مع محمد رمضان
كما اثارت الجدل في فيلم مش انا مع تامر
حسني حيث طلبت من المخرج حذف مشاهد لها
رغم ان ارتداء الحجاب يعتبر قرارا خاصا
لاي امراه الا ان الجمهور يهتم بشكل خاص
بهذا الموضوع اذا كانت صاحبته فنانه فسبق
واثارت الفنانه صابرين الجدل ايضا بعد
عودتها للتمثيل وارتدائها الباروكه قبل ان
تقرر خلال الحجاب فهل الحياه الخاصه لاي
فنان ملك له واحده ام ان هناك ضريبه
للشهره سؤال ليس له اجابه حتى اليوم سمر
بشات لصباح العربيه من القاهره
[موسيقى]
حالا شيحه يعني حره في حوار خلي الحجاب او
مش خلل الحجاب هي حره وانعم وكل واحد حر
في شخصيته حر بطريقه تفكيره وحر في
تصرفاته هو انعم بس اهم حاجه المجتمع
بتصرفه لان هي شخصيه تؤثر على المجتمع
كتير قوي والله انا شافها الحاجات دي حاجه
حريه شخصيه بس هي كفنانه فطبعا ممثله
عظيمه وكبيره بس الحجاب دي تبقى حريه
شخصيه للبني ادم تمام عودتها حلوه لكنها
تقلع الحجاب دي حاجه ثانيه ان انت لو
كنتيش عايزه تقلعي الحجاب همم كنتيش
تلبسيه من الاول للتمثيل العادي حريتها
لكن ان هي تخلع للحجاب بعدها ترجع للتمثيل
فانا مش مع الحاجه دي لانه هي بتعتبر
ممثله وقدوه للبنات كتير فانه هي ترجع
للتمثيل كانت ممكن ترجع بحجابها عادي
والله انا شايفه انه حلا شيحه وغيرها كثير
همم ان ده قرار يخصها هي سواء هي حابه
تلبس الحجاب او تقلعه دي علاقتها بربنا
مفيش حد من حقه ان هو يتدخل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من القاهره ينضم الينا الناقد الفني طارق
الشناوي سيد طارق اهلا بك معنا من جديد
صباح العربيه قبل سنوات كانت اعلنت حلا
اعتزالها وكذلك قامت بارتداء الحجاب
واليوم يعود الجدل نفسه ما الذي يحصل
تحديدا مرحله
هو ليس تحديدا مع حلا وان كانت حاله هي
الغلاف انما المجتمع المصري
بوجه الخصوص متارجح بين ارتداء الحجاب
وبين خلع الحجاب
حلل انها نجمه فبالتالي دايما المتابعه
بتبقى او بتبقى بتتحول الى ترند والمتابعه
بتبقى عاليه جدا لكنها ظاهره اجتماعيه لن
اناقش الجانب الفقهي هل هو هل الحجاب فرد
او غير فرد ولكن ما استطيع ان اقوله ان كل
حفلات ام كلثوم المصوره في التلفزيون خلال
الستينيات ومطلع السبعينيات لم تكن النساء
في مصر
بيرتددني الحجاب ما كانش لم يكن هناك حجاب
ولا نقاب طب شارع فقط فقط ارجوك لو سمحتي
صارت ما نتحدث عن الحجاب نتحدث عن حاله
كنجمه لها جمهور ونحبها كلنا يعني حاله
تحديدا شو عم بيصير معها
[موسيقى]
ما هو ده مدخل حتى اعتزال
ما هي ما هي بتعبر بس بشكل خاص عن الحيره
اللي بتعيشها بيعيشها المجتمع بس ففكره
الحجاب انما فيها في حاله زجزاجيه متعرجه
حالها لما في سنه 2008 عملت فيلم اسمه
كامل الاوصاف كانت ارتدت الحجاب وفي
القاهره وعملت الفيلم مقاييس الحجاب يعني
ايه مقاييس الحجاب يعني هي مثلا لما بتكون
الست وهي في في بيتها لا ترتدي الحجاب
طالما مع اهلها لكن هي في الفيلم كانت
بترتدي الحجاب على اساس انها بتطبق
المعايير الدينيه على العمل الفني لما
تركب اسانسير كانت بتشترط انه ما بيكونش
معاها رجل يعني عايز اقول انها من 2009
و2008 الموقف ده موجود مع حلقه اختلفت
طريقه التعبير اتحجبت واتنقبت وكانت
احيانا داعيه
عادت خلعه الحجاب وعدت للتمثيل ثم
تنكرت لاخر افلامها اللي هو مع تامر حسني
ثم
اتحجبت ثم ابتعدت ثم عادت بصور بالحجاب
التارجح ده تارجح شخصي لكن له يعبر عن
قضيه اكبر من ظروف شخصيه هو ده الموضوع
طيب طارق هل بعد ما قعدت بالصور هل نتوقع
لحاله ان تعود للساحه الفنيه والتمثيل
مؤكد انه ساعات الجمهور وهو متباين في
جمهور بيحكم على الفنان بيصلي او بيصوم او
بيحج وفي جمهور اخر بيحكم عليه على الشاشه
فيجب ان نهايه تتوقع ان اللي بيحكم على
الفنان اخلاقيا او بيعتقد انه مظاهر
الصلاه والصوم والحج وكل الطقوس دي جزء
مهم جدا في حب الفنان او عدم حبه هتخسر
القطاع ده لكن في قطاع بيحكم على الشاشه
فقط اكيد المتابعات على السوشيال ميديا
تباينت فيها الاراء هناك من يرفض خلعها
للحجاب وهناك من يراها انها حريه شخصيه
وده انعكاس لما يجري بالضبط في المجتمع
المصري وربما ايضا في دوائر اخرى المجتمع
العربي شكرا جزيلا من القاهره ناقد الفني
طارق الشناوي